David Spade has a new show boy their
hand in the mount lights out with David
Spade made its debut last night
Comedy Central airs every Monday through
Thursday 11:30 Eastern David welcome to
the program and congrats on your new
show apparently apparently that's nice
are you a Cardinal fan Arizona Cardinal
fan you know Dan this is a great
question I am from Scottsdale and I grew
up there
they weren't there as I recall so I
glommed on to the Miami Dolphins of the
kids because because they were winning
and they were undefeated and I loved you
know like Larry Csonka okay to my show
once I couldn't believe I loved the song
I love mercury Morris then we had to say
dealer now I loved mercury Morris and
then my and then they started losing so
I switched to the Steelers and I had a
good run with them and I realized I just
was loyal to winning I just like the
Steelers no rhyme or reason just because
they started winning a lot and then I
realized I don't even know what loyal
means I just like the teams that win are
you a Patriots fan yeah what if fans say
to you when they see you on the street
they say enough with the Adam Sandler
stuff no they say David thank you for
your service and show business you've
done it you've done right by everyone
and I know I can always count on seeing
you it on TV as a 3 p.m. on something
are you okay charmers are you do you put
do you find that that you that you've
got to be funny when you see like they
expect you to be funny or do they give
you the benefit of the doubt no matter
what you say that it's funny or coming
from a comedian well I did there's a
couple levels that first of all I do
when I meet people and I know there
just going to meet me once in their life
sometimes I say something goofy you're
funny because that's it for life if you
meet someone famous and you're from out
of town that's the story you have for 20
years and you want it to be a pleasant
experience just even if I just nice and
I take a picture or something as I feel
like I've done that growing up and I
just remembered it forever with people
and if they're nice you're just happy
about it but sometimes like waiters and
some of them they will laugh extra hard
when I say anything and then my a girl
I'm withers I was like it's so gross how
your little feet Plus jokes it should be
balmy and this guy's like oh they're not
even joke I go I don't care I love it
yeah but you've been tricking them for a
long time David oh yeah it's been I've
got it wired now yeah but I just
I try to be okay in real life and I know
on TV I come across like a tough-guy
hard-ass athlete but in real life I'm
actually like sort of a nice guy kind of
a puss and so you have to a lot of guys
treat me like it's all Joe Dirt like
slapping on the back like I'm a like on
their little buddy and I'm like a frat
brother and they're like look at this
idiot you know brick in a headlock
I'm like all right relax and then I have
with Sean Penn and they're like mr. Penn
I'm like give me some of that hey what
is the deal about act you know the actor
Sean Penn did he give you your first
tattoo yes he did I think I'm gonna ask
him to another one in the new show her
stealer thirsty thirsty yeah because I
want that was a fun one on Senate Live I
was just such a dumb idea he had only
done it on up potatoes wait so he gives
you a tent you were okay signing off on
that so the real deal your tattoo is
Sean Penn over to my real deal is I ran
in him at a party I didn't know him I
heard him talking and telling someone
else he's trying to do tattoos just for
some time to kill or some sort of drunk
talk and I did on a potato and then I
was out of ideas immediately honest
about a week later called him and said
would you come to SNL when you're doing
Letterman would you run over and give me
a tattoo and he said yeah okay and we
always very not thought through I can
tell you that and then I I picked one
that Steven Tyler had I asked even Tyler
for this one he has in his arm he
nice-enough told me how to get it
whatever I show up at the tattoo shop
there's two Hells Angels Shawn strong
and and then he goes I can't do that one
of them the tattoo guy goes oh yeah this
is what you meant he can't do that he
can't do anything so we had to pick
something on the newspaper which was
Calvin and Hobbes which I didn't want
and I go well here we go let's this will
be a fun bit for the rest of my life and
he did it and I interviewed him and just
added some dumb questions and and then
at the end I I was allergic to every
color and the whole thing bled and then
I said who wants to choose they're
horrible like it's no fun at all and and
they are am trying to do it again with
him he's David Spade he as a new show it
debuted last night on Comedy Central and
this is after the Daily Show is this
after Trevor Noah yeah I know it's on
your VCR but maybe the next month or two
you should try to keep a few minutes of
it all right so it's 11:30 Eastern
Monday through Thursday
give me your guest who's the ideal guest
oh I do want to quiz Le'Veon Bell about
fantasy last year I don't think he'll be
my first guest but I'm still stewing
about it and I'm glad he made a
statement pointed at me because I
drafted him first last year and now I'm
still I'm scared to draft him again yeah
I remember when we had you on you were
really angry
steaming and I apologize I was really in
a tizzy but this year I feel like fool
me once shame on you if I do it again
I'm gonna go to safe route with is eco
will you take levy on bail if you have a
chance and these are the tough questions
what is it 60 minutes yes I I think I
will because now Ezekiel is
no knees he's playing grab-ass he's down
in Cabo come on your head in the game
I need guys that want to be there yeah I
know that I know practicing my speech
for my writers how good are you in
fantasy football
oh I don't know I wanted one oh man
league is that good and such a crapshoot
though I think I'm good and then I get
like last the next year I go what am I
doing wrong
but you know it's just fun I do it was
something like I wasn't happy Madison
and then I have another one with some of
my idiot friends around here but they
always hate if I'm winning you're like
okay he gets at all - but you know what
they probably think you get inside
information because you're David Spade
you know like you could call Adam
Schefter or somebody I do I called
Glazer sometimes really like he's like
hey did you get that up Soloflex I sent
you like yes I got another question but
are the Dennis mics off I don't hear
anything
they're there you know what we put in a
laugh track after the interview please
God help me my I don't want to bomb
pushing a show yeah I could you guys
open up your microphones a little bit
[Laughter]
what is your demo we dominated in that
movie didn't we
dude I'm telling you I hear about
Benchwarmers as much as almost any movie
not as much as Joe Dirt or Tommy Boy no
but I'm telling you it's Joe Dirt and
Tommy Boy which is two good guesses
because those are one and two and then
I'm I'm telling you Benchwarmers is a
real sleeper because I hear it on
Twitter almost every day and it's just a
good little fun baseball movie that had
some dumb lines in it and I first of all
appreciate you being in it and I'm glad
you're in a lot of those movies and
you're sort of a lucky charm are you is
Twitter nice to you overall
yes overall except about once a week I
get I wish you died instead of Farley I
swear I get that more than I should and
now it's turning into like a sample of a
song where you go I've heard that so
much come up with some new stuff but the
truth is that they can be mean Dan and I
don't want you to get on Twitter if
you're not ready I'm not on Twitter I
don't want to and I'm sorry they said
such a mean thing like that
yeah we really nice to you but I'm like
one of my ariana grande leave me alone
you know I'm old I already I've already
ate myself you don't have to dive in on
it man you both dated Pete Davidson so
there you go that guy all right wait you
have a beef with Pete Davidson no no
it's more with Ariana Grande's ponytail
listen Dan is it you're going to I gotta
run I got a million things going okay
wait wait wait say it again say it again
and then I'm gonna get a real laugh from
my guys okay okay
all right Damon well wait what's the
setup I I didn't have one you were gonna
just take it you were running with it
okay
guys I gotta run I've got a I got to go
turn down some movies okay okay okay I
can't miss you if you don't leave thank
you David
it's David Spade isn't who a new TV show
it's called light salad with David Spade
at debuted last night and it's Monday
through Thursday 11:30 Eastern for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]